you're looking at video of author
solomon rushdie being violently attacked
while on stage moments before he was set
to give a lecture in new york police say
he was stabbed at least once in the neck
and abdomen but witnesses to the attack
say the suspect either stabbed or
punched rushdie 10 to 15 times over the
course of 20 seconds
his agent saying tonight the news is not
good he will likely lose one eye the
nerves in his arm were severed and his
liver was stabbed and damaged he is on a
ventilator and cannot speak the 24 year
old was taken into custody immediately
after the attack joining me now is
raymond arroyo fox news contributor so
raymond good to see you and
do you see an iranian connection here on
this story and what can you tell us
there clearly is an iranian connection
back in 1989 when solomon rushdie made
his name releasing his book the satanic
verses the mullahs in iran were very
upset they issued a fatwa
a death sentence on on rushdie and since
that time two of his translators were
stabbed his publisher was shot and now
we see the accused assailant a man named
as you mentioned hari matar now matar
has posted shiite extremism and is a
supporter of the iranian government so
there's a connection here this is the
regime joe biden incidentally wants to
do a nuke deal with but it shows you
what happens when you demonize thought
and free expression and individuals this
is the sad outcome look sean when the da
vinci code was released a lot of
catholics were very upset they didn't
chase dan brown through the streets
similarly when the book of mormon came
out mormons didn't fire bomb the eugene
o'neill theater it's still running on
broadway we have to in an open society
be able to consider questions that have
free debate not death and the iranians
even have come out with hits on
um bolton and maybe even pompeo so this
doesn't end this continues with the
iranians and you make a good point why
would joe biden ever want to do a deal
with the iranians but i want to turn
quickly to the 2024
election biden allies are now reportedly
pushing him to launch his campaign
sooner rather than later according to
reuters people involved in planning
biden's campaign said that an early
announcement would be a smart step for
biden sending a signal to the general
public that biden is no lame duck and
that democrats are unified behind his
agenda his personality and his
leadership raymond his personality and
his leadership what say why are they so
eager
well they're so eager because they see
this as a moment of victory that's how
they're trying to cast you know that he
passed the shrunken down build back
better plan and he's got a 40-year high
in inflation i guess that's victorious
you know sean it reminded me of that
poor carriage horse we saw this week in
new york city it was pulling its
carriage and it fell over in the street
now some might call that a thoroughbred
but that thing ain't moving it's going
to lay there and it's probably time to
put it out to pasture and if you look at
the polls there was a poll done by
something called premise it's a software
company of democrats 61 percent of those
democrats said joe biden should not run
again but the people they'd like to see
run kamala harris at 21 hillary clinton
at 19 and little bootage and and gavin
newsom are fighting it out at nine
percent so they want biden to step in to
sort of take center stage and repel
these uh attackers of the throne why
here's the big reason why because they
fear this more than anything else here's
your vice president from earlier today
so equity as a concept says
recognize
that everyone has the same capacity but
in order for them to have equal
opportunity to reach that capacity
what we must pay attention to this issue
of equity
equity capacity who knows good look sean
that they are they are more willing to
go with a basement campaigner that they
can control with joe biden you don't
quite know what's coming out of his
mouth with kamala harris we know exactly
what's coming out it just doesn't make
any sense you know raymond it's actually
good politics if you have these
challengers around you that you think
that could run it's important to
announce early though uh again i don't
think america wants to see him again i
just quickly only have a couple seconds
15 seconds left the fox news poll showed
that the right direction wrong direction
numbers it wasn't republicans who had a
large the largest number of america
going the wrong direction it was
independence how do you win races when
independents are saying at the highest
level the country's in the wrong
direction
look the democrats are saying that the
democrats don't want joe biden that
tells you the policies aren't working
and he's not the torchbearer that
they're trying to cast him as here and
clearly kamala harris all she could
repeat is torch bearer torch bear a
torchbearer but it doesn't add up to
anything there's no constituency there
and they know it you don't get better
results unless you have better policies
raymond thank you for joining me good to
see you equity sean
yes complementarity equity i gotta go
you equity manual great weekend hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else